mesdames et messieurs chers amis je
voudrais vous proposer de prendre place
que nous puissions démarré nos travaux
voilà je voudrais vous remercier d'avoir
bravé les éléments les incertitudes en
matière de transport et de services
publics pour venir débattre d'un sujet
si important pour l'avenir de notre pays
qui est la place de la fonction publique
et ce que nous avons baptisé une action
publique renouvelé je voudrais remercier
notre secrétaire général eric woerth qui
est en charge du projet
le projet du mouvement savez que c'est
important que notre mouvement dans la
perspective de 2017 se dote d'un projet
qui sera débattu devant les français et
votre présence nombreuse témoigne de
l'intérêt que vous portez les uns les
autres
à ce sujet si important alors je
voudrais en quelques instants pour
saluer tous les parlementaires des amis
parlementaires qui sont ici présents qui
ont travaillé ils vous tous vous
remercier d'avoir pris de votre temps
pour contribuer dans le cas des groupes
de travail à ce projet je voudrais en
quelques instants vous faire partager
quelques réflexions sur à la fois mon
expérience j'ai été à la tête de la
première administration de france
l'éducation nationale mais j'ai été
aussi maire je suis parlementaire et
vous faire partager quelques réflexions
sur ce que doit être à mon sens
aujourd'hui notre vision à nous les
républicains de la fonction publique
je crois que la question que nous devons
d'abord nous poser c'est celle qu'elle
fonction publique pour la france du
xxième siècle le monde a été bouleversé
en quelques années avec l'accélération
du temps et de l'espace que constitue la
mondialisation avec l'avènement du
numérique avec cette société que l'on
baptise collaborative qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est plus dans une
logique transversale horizontale qu'une
logique purement verticale tous ces
changements vont un petit peu à
l'encontre du schéma de la fonction
publique la vision de l'état que nous
avions dans les années 60 70 ou à la fin
du dernier siècle
donc nous avons des bouleversements
considérables que nous devons nous les
républicains accompagner et donc la
question n'est pas uniquement une
question financière budgétaire
bien sûr elle l'est il y avait 4
millions 400 mille fonctionnaires taux
de fonction publique réunis en 1980 à 5
millions 600 mille aujourd'hui + 30 % en
25 ans quelle est l'entreprise qui a
augmenté de 30 % ses effectifs en 25 ans
et qui n'a pas été capable de mesurer
l'efficacité de ses performances
c'est le cas aujourd'hui de la fonction
publique au sens large et la question
majeure c'est celle du coût efficacité
aujourd'hui est-ce que la fonction
publique au sens large est à l' otan tu
à la hauteur des attentes de nos
concitoyens
si à mon avis la seule question qui
vaille et les républicains doivent à mon
sens prendre le débat sous cet angle je
sais que certains nos adversaires vont
nous caricaturer on est en toi sont ils
n'aiment pas les fonctionnaires là nous
nous aimons les fonctionnaires moi j'ai
été j'ai été fier
d'être à la tête d'un million de
fonctionnaires qui tous les matins sont
au quotidien aux côtés des enfants des
familles pour leur transmettre le savoir
c'est difficile d'être fonctionnaires et
ils méritent que l'on soit à leurs côtés
pour les aider à améliorer leurs
conditions de travail pour leur donner
davantage de perspectives et que au
total l'état donne remplissent mieux la
mission qui lui est confiée
c'est à mon sens là là le sujet le plus
important et je voudrais rapidement
abordé évoqué trois questions trois
questions que les républicains doivent
se poser dans le cadre de cette
convention et dans les mois qui viennent
la première question c'est celle du
périmètre d'intervention de l'état
dans ce monde où tout a été chamboulé où
tous les repères ont été chamboulées et
si nous commencions par nous poser la
question qu'est ce qui doit rester du
domaine de la compétence de l'état
à force de vouloir tout faire
l'état fait au mal l'état dit lui les
responsabilités et à la fin la
performance vis-à-vis du client final je
dis un gros mot l'usagé le contribuable
elle diminue donc nous devons nous poser
comme première question qu'est-ce qui
devra rester du ressort du périmètre
d'intervention de l'état
qu'est-ce qui devra au contraire être
transférée en matière de missions soit à
d'autres niveaux de collectivités soit
au privé il soit au monde associatif
regardez le succès de david cameron avec
sa big society donc en tout cas c'est un
débat absolument majeur que nous devons
avoir le périmètre d'intervention de
l'état
aujourd'hui tout le monde se pose cette
question quand je dis tout le monde
les grandes entreprises se posent cette
question en disant mais finalement quel
est mon coeur de business qu'est ce qui
est le coeur de mon activité qui n'est
pas négociable et que je doit exercer en
direct qu'est-ce qui au contraire doit
être exercée par d'autres questions
être externalisés ce sont de bonnes
questions les pays qui ont profondément
réformé leur fonction publique se sont
posé cette question
regardez ce qui s'est fait au canada
regardez ce qui s'est fait en europe du
nord
c'est à mon sens la première des
questions aujourd'hui on peut par
exemple s'interroger sur la nécessité
ultime que le service de l'emploi soit
absolument géré par le public veut dire
on pourrait imaginer dans d'autres pays
vous avez des organismes privés qui
accomplissent avec peut-être plus
d'efficacité je n'en sais rien c'est à
regarder de près avec moindre coût la
gestion du service de l'emploi
donc le périmètre d'intervention d'état
la deuxième question une fois que nous
aurons répondu à cette question
nous devons immédiatement nous imposer
une deuxième pour les sphères de
compétence de l'état qui est le mieux à
même de remplir la mission de service
public parce que c'est pas parce que
vous avez défini une sphère de
compétence de l'état que c'est
nécessairement des agents de la fonction
publique d'état qui mettent en oeuvre
ces projets guette ses prérogatives
aujourd'hui vous avez des tas de
domaines dans lequel les collectivités
publiques interviennent sont les
domaines de l'état ou des collectivités
locales et leurs missions ne sont pas
nécessairement exercées par des agents
de la fonction publique d'état et ou de
la fonction publique territoriale
vous avez même dans les fonctions
régaliennes des contrats qui sont des
contrats de droit privé moi j'ai un
régiment de drones à chaumont et bien
les ce qui
ger organise affecte les drones ce sont
des militaires de droits ceux des
contrats de droit privé de cinq ans bon
donc nous devrons immédiatement après la
question du périmètre d'intervention
avoir cette question sur ce que
j'appelle le statut
quel statut pour quelles missions est-ce
que nécessairement ce sont des agents de
la fonction publique d'état
la fonction publique territoriale qui
gère des fonctions des prérogatives des
compétences de l'état et ou des
collectivités territoriales puis enfin
je dirais que la troisième question que
nous devons nous poser qui est sans
doute la plus importante c'est la
question de quelle valeur pour l'état
employeur que le devront être ce qui m'a
frappé de mon expérience au ministère de
l'éducation nationale
c'est que l'état n'est pas un bon
gestionnaire de ses ressources humaines
l'état n'est pas un bon employeur
j'ai été drh dans une autre vie dans une
grande entreprise
j'ai pu comparer la situation et moi je
suis frappé de voir à quel point nous
décourageons les agents de la fonction
publique par notre incapacité à bien
définir leur mission notre incapacité à
anticiper les évolutions de ses missions
notre incapacité à proposer des
perspectives d'évolution de carrière
pour les agents de faire tomber les
barrières de fluidifier le système
nous devons absolument sortir d'une
logique de statuts dans la fonction
publique pour entrer de ce que
j'appellerais une logique de carrière de
perspectives de carrière nos valeurs
c'est quoi c'est le travail et le mérite
eh bien il faut que dans la fonction
publique nous soyons capables
d'appliquer ces valeurs du travail et du
mérite
un agent qui travaille qui a envie de
travailler plus que les autres et doit
pouvoir travailler plus que les autres
un agent qui réussit mieux j'ai dit un
gros mot que les autres que les voisins
il doit pouvoir parce qu'il a de
meilleures performances que les autres
être mieux noté que les autres et donc
avoir des perspectives d'évolution
supérieur aux autres
un agent
qui ne un agent qui ne réussit pas il
doit pouvoir être sanctionné on doit
sortir enfin du système os pour se
débarrasser d'un agent incompétent on a
qu'une seule solution c'est de le
promouvoir
c'est aujourd'hui le système de la
fonction publique d'état que nous
connaissons trop dans nos collectivités
j'ai l'exemple que je garderai hanté
toute ma vie d'un ancien directeur
d'hôpital de chaumont qui étaient
notoirement incompétents dont en tant
que président du conseil de surveillance
j'avais voulu me débarrasser en tout cas
j'avais alerté fortement à plusieurs
reprises l'agencé régionale de santé et
bien le jour où mon président mon
directeur parlant d' agences régionales
de santé m'a indiqué que le problème
était réglé
il m'a indiqué qu'il avait été réglé en
promouvant ce directeur dans un hôpital
de taille plus importante
voilà aujourd'hui c'est ça la situation
de la fonction publique dans notre pays
l'état pour répondre à ce que j'appelle
ces valeurs que nous partageons l'état
il doit être ingénieux innovants plus
agile plus proche de la réalité locale
il va falloir que nous inventions des
solutions nouvelles nous allons avoir
dans des secteurs des agents compétents
qui vont être disponibles et nous aurons
des missions pour lesquelles nous
n'avons pas d'argent à disposition
nous devons inventer de nouveaux système
de mutualisation
je parlais récemment être le président
de la poste sur val
la poste va être confronté un système de
gestion des ressources humaines
effrayant parce qu'ils ont plus de
courrier ils ont des facteurs qui vont
devoir payer qu'on a encore 30 ans est
bien est ce qu'on pourrait pas inventé
des systèmes de mutualisation entre les
collectivités locales la poche des
grandes organisations publiques privées
bref l'état doit être capable
d'organiser des mutualisations nouvelles
des partenariat nouveau entre des
collectivités publiques des
collectivités privées et lui même c'est
un défi absolument majeur que nous
devrons absolument relever
gestionnaire des ressources humaines
j'ai été frappée j'avais initié un
chantier important au ministère
l'éducation nationale qui était celui de
l'évaluation des enseignants le système
d'évaluation des enseignants aujourd'hui
est le plus absurde qui soit le plus
absurde
vous avez une évaluation en moyenne tous
les sept ans avec un inspecteur au tout
ça est organisé à l'avancé et entendu où
on va apprécier uniquement la compétence
pédagogique de l'enseignant dans sa
classe pendant trois quarts d'heure
alors que toute la mission qui tourne
autour de ce qui se passe dans la classe
n'est absolument pas apprécié nous
avions décidé qu'il fallait qu'ils aient
un chef un responsable ce soit le chef
d'établissement est bien le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui à abroger ces mesures qui
à mon sens et des mesures d'adaptation
au monde d'aujourd'hui
si vous voulez responsabiliser les
agents il faut que ceux qui travaillent
davantage
il faut que ceux qui en ont sous la
soit davantage responsabilisés et soit
mieux évaluer donc il vous faut un
système d'évaluation adaptés à cela qui
permettent ensuite des perspectives
d'évolution beaucoup plus importante
voilà alors tout au long de cette
matinée nous allons avoir de nombreux
débats vous avez beaucoup de sujets qui
seront évoqués
je sais qu'il ya dans la salle des
experts des spécialistes de renom nous
avons la chance d'avoir les
parlementaires qui à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat sont les experts
également du sujet c'est un rendez vous
important voilà il faut pas que nous ne
voyons la fonction publique que sous
l'angle comptable
bien sûr c'est important les finances
publiques quand vous avez chaque année
cinq milliards d'euros supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire 10% du produit de l'impôt
sur le revenu
cinq milliards d'euros supplémentaires
qui sont affectés aux dérapages de la
masse salariale
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet absolument
majeur mais gardons-nous de n'utiliser
de ne voir que cet angle la fonction
publique
c'est une chance pour notre pays nous
avons été bien content d'avoir les
fonctionnaires que nous
avons en france aujourd'hui dans la
période que nous venons de traverser
avec les attentats de novembre
nous sommes bien contents d'avoir un
service public de qualité tous les
matins qui fournit les services en
matière je lui dis d'éducation mais
aussi dans certains domaines
en matière de transports ou dans le
domaine régalien simplement ce service
pour survivre il doit s'adapter au monde
d'aujourd'hui
nous sommes le parti de la modernité
nous les républicains nous allons
aujourd'hui vous proposer un certain
nombre de pistes pour faire entrer la
fonction publique dans le 21e siècle
merci